jd went on another hike yesterday john
took him on a hike
and here he is again way out of breath
i keep staring at like how high
everything is going as we're walking and
then i got this
[ __ ] after uh what uh i mean y'all
here what
what are your 10 favorite animals
who cares
all right we're listening to
jd
10 favorite animals and why
i just want to do a [ __ ] ball john
i can't even name tim and animals right
now
action welcome to
jd harmeyer's 10 favorite animals and
why i just said
i'm getting your name that animal right
now
yeah mandy you you are out of shape to
name animals
why don't you just say like elephant
giraffe dog cat well i wanna i wanna
think things through i wanna be able to
you know you don't want to make a
mistake
i want to be able to defend my answers
right you don't want to say accidentally
the wrong animal and it's not just
oregon don't and you don't have a reason
for that exactly and you know you love
you love chickens
because you love chicken nuggets i do
love chickens
chickens
you know dogs cats uh
well i don't know
do you know animals that's a good
question exactly
well do i say this jd will either be
dead or have abs by friday so
[Laughter]
we'll see about that was it any easier
was it the same um place no it's
different place he was angrier this time
it was like it's like hiking with an
angry bear and you gotta just be careful
because he he may swipe at you or attack
so you gotta i should tell some i should
tell some funny things
that uh
that john did to jd
what did he do
they got in an elevator yesterday and
somebody had a big giant blow up bear
like it almost took up the whole
elevator and then john yells out jd take
a picture with the bear
it's for valentine's day and then
suddenly there's a photo shoot of jd and
the bear and and we got it in the mail
yesterday you know the email and i was
like no explanation john doesn't put it
it's just a big picture of jd with a
bear
when they were hiking and jd could
barely breathe
john walked up to people and said by the
way this is his very first hike since
his surgery
and um
and all the people were like good for
you and like cheering jd on oh they
started clapping
i can't do anything
we're just past people i was like give
them a bite of applause it's the first
hike since the surgery they're like oh
yeah
and i'm so i'm so winded i can't say
anything back i'm just walking
yeah i mean
oh my god his doctor said it'd be okay
he's like shut the [ __ ] up john
shut up
i think there's some uh there's some
clips of you doing your schtick parking
it's his first time hiking shut up
when john's like telling other people
i'm drawing attention to you which you
hate and he's like hey it's his first
hike
yes you know since and they start
applauding do you get embarrassed or do
you of course
of course i'm just like i'm just like i
don't even look at them i just keep
walking i'm looking straight ahead i
just i'm avoiding the situation and
getting out of this area
they were walking down the street or on
the hike or something and john would go
up and say and he asked two young ladies
if they wanted a picture with j.d
oh
there's these girls at the restaurant
yeah and you know they said baba bowie
and i said you know hello hello we were
like about to leave
and so then john walked back into the
area and goes do you want a picture with
jd and they were like we'd love that
we would love that
yeah jd
buys his fan he's like hi bye you know
you gotta be gracious
that is horrible next time we run we do
runyon canyon i could have
next time when there's
we're back in l.a give me this trip have
head shots like a stack of headshots and
offers right to sign yeah hand them out
like a headshot you're gonna
for free um
anyway uh good luck boys but the boys
are still in la and uh yes i'll be
coming home more highs to follow i don't
think they're done out there yet